contre ma volonté j'ai été le témoin de
la plus effroyable défaite de la raison
et du plus sauvage triomphe de la
brutalité jamais une génération n'est
tombée d'une telle élévation spirituelle
dans une telle décadence morale quand il
écrit ces mots Stéphan Zwag a fui la
barbarie nazie et un continent submergé
par la haine antisémite que les
démocraties n'avaient pas su étouffer à
temps zvag ne ne survivra pas à une
civilisation qu'il savait défigurer
notre civilisation qui comme l'écrivait
malero et la part de l'homme que qu
auront voulu détruire alors que le
peuple israélien a subi les pires
atrocités nous devons constater hélas
que le soutien indéfectible qu'aurait dû
recevoir Israël est meurtri par un
effroyable relativisme et une ignoble
flambé
d'antisémitisme pire
encore pire encore l'hyre odieuse de la
haine des Juifs ne vient pas s'écraser
contre un mur unanime de boucliers de
glèv de nos démocraties pour la battre
mais ce fr un chemin à travers
l'indifférence la leté et le
clientélisme l'adre antisémite s'abreuve
encore dans le canivau des extrémismes
mais sa source essentielle sa source
cardinale est désormais l'islamisme
l'islamisme aux souterraines que les
nations laisser s'infiltrer jaillit à
nos visages et peut nous submerger faute
de réaction à la hauteur de la
catastrophe dans nos rues nos écoles au
sein des médias du sport de la culture
et même des plus grandes universités la
haine des Juifs est partout de l'insulte
jusqu'au meurtre qu'avons-nous fait du
devoir de mémoire avons-nous oublié que
la barbarie triomp des illusions de
genens de bien qui pense vaincre par la
simple raison je dis nous je dis nous
car dans un tel moment aucune division
n'est tolérable Marc bloc affirmé ne
revendiquer son origine que face à un
antisémite il est temps que la France la
République revendique sa civilisation
ses valeurs et son destin contre les
antisémites alors qu'un imam àer n reçu
qu'une peine dérisoire pour avoir profép
mon cher
cègue je vous
remercie la parole est à Monsieur
Olivier verrand porte-parole du
gouvernement et ministre en charge du
renouveau démocratique merci madame la
Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés monsieur le député
Tangui l'antisémitisme qui s'exprime sur
les frontons de nos maisons sur les
portes des immeubles dans les injures
qui peuvent être lancées dans les rames
de métro cet antisémitisme qui fait
qu'une partie de nos concitoyens n'os
plus faire ses courses normalement n'os
plus mettre ses enfants dans les écoles
normalement n'os plus aller au travail
normalement n'os plus prendre des
transports en commun normalement cette
entitétisme est un fléo que nous
condamnons tous et que nous devons
combattre avec acharnement il est
autant il est autant une hérésie
temporaelle qu'un
anachronisme cet antisémitisme il n'est
pas né au lendemain du 7 octobre il
avait un antisémitisme pernicieux
insidieux parfois révélé à travers des
actes antisémites je rappelle que la
France déplorait déjà plusieurs
centaines d'actes de cette nature chaque
année cet antisémitisme il croit
désormais dans l'esprit de certain qu'il
serait légitime à exploser au grand jour
comme légitimé par un conflit
israélo-palestinien qui permettrait
enfin à ceux qui ont toujours Hai les
Juifs en secret de pouvoir le faire
cette fois-ci à raison et dans la sphère
publique monsieur le député nous
combattons cet antisémitisme tous ici
dans cette hémicycle monsieur le député
je peux je ne peux imaginer qu'un député
de la nation je ne peux imaginer qu'un
député de la nation ne puisse ne puisse
combattre l'antisémitisme mais il n'y a
pas monsieur le député et je le dira ici
sans polémique il n'y a pas vous pointez
l'extrême gauche je vais vous pointezv
vous êtes le parti de la flamme il n'y a
pas un bon et un bon et un mauvais
antisémitisme il n'y a qu'un
antisémitisme et quand le président de
votre parti politique il y a 2 jours
refuse de reconnaître que le président
fondateur de votre parti le Front
Nationale a été condamné par la justice
française pour antisémitisme vous ne
servez pas la côte que vous prétendez
servir alors soyons tous unis une fois
pour toute contre l'antisémitisme sans
réserve dans tous les bords de
l'hémicycle c'est ainsi la grandeur de
la France Merci monsieur le
ministre je vous remercie
un peu de silence s'il vous plaît un peu
de
silence